bonjour mérienne alors selon l'onu 5
million et demi de vénézuéliens ont fui
le pays ces dernières années ces exilés
se retrouve dans les autres pays du
continent où les populations locales ne
veulent pas voir le scénario vénézuélien
se reproduire alors meriem comment
expliquer ce phénomène
bonjour olivier oui durant les campagnes
électorales en amérique latine la droite
libérale soutenue par les médias très
souvent et utilise utilise la situation
économique au venezuela à son profit
comme nous l'avons souvent traités sur
rt france cette crise économique
s'explique avant tout par les sanctions
appliquées par washington et par ses
alliés occidentaux afin de chasser
nicolas maduro du pouvoir des sanctions
qui ont exacerbé les calamités selon la
rapporteur spéciale de l'onu dans notre
article nous expliquons d'ailleurs à
quel point c'est une stratégie voulue
par les etats-unis d' affamer le peuple
vénézuélien jusqu'à ce qu'ils se soulève
contre son gouvernement
mais dans le reste du continent la
réalité et vénézuéliennes avec son flot
de migrants est brandie par la droite
libérale comme un épouvantail pour dire
soit vous votez pour nous pour la droite
soit vous aurez le venezuela et le chaos
qui va avec laure meriem comment réagit
la gauche face à cela et bien la gauche
se retrouve dans l'embarras comme vous
pouvez l'imaginer surtout pendant les
campagnes électorales où elle doit
convaincre alors elle souffle le chaud
et le froid
bien sûr elle maintient une position
anti impérialiste qui constitue son adn
en rejetant les sanctions économiques
qu'elle qualifie de criminel et
l'ingérence de washington à travers la
figure de wang wei d'eau qui est vu
comme un pantin des états unis et en
même temps elle tente de rassurer les
populations en promettant nous ne
reproduirons pas le scénario la
situation au venezuela
notre pays selon le pays n'est pas dans
le même contexte économique ne disposent
pas des mêmes richesses que le venezuela
nous aurons une bonne gestion sociale
etc en bref un dilemme est expliqué en
long et en large dans notre article que
j invite les téléspectateurs à lire
merci beaucoup meriem on retrouve vous
venez de le lire tous vos articles sur
notre site rtl france point tv